my son Leon was taken away by his own  mother I helped this child with seven to  completely dependent on her for care and  nurturing  instead became a victim of her careless  and self-centered actions within a few  short days  a grieving father there speaks out after  his son was killed by the child's own  mother we begin with that breaking news  and she killed her seven-year-old son  last year and this morning the mother  who pleaded guilty to killing that  little boy who had autism finds out just  how long she'll be spending Behind Bars  thanks for joining us this afternoon I'm  Heather Mills Samantha Moreno Rodriguez  sentenced to 28 years to life in prison  she killed her son Liam and dumped his  body near a trail in Mountain Springs he  was found by hikers in May last year she  pleaded guilty to charges of murdered  child abuse and neglect resulting in  bodily harm she won't be eligible for  parole until after she serves 20 years